game today I hope everybody's on their
game because Taffer is looking around
going like what can I improve here what
can I improve hi messing around right I
know I know it hi John it's not just
bars it's systems
do you ever offer opinions and your
places and people don't want your
opinion is not like meaning like you're
not at work but you're doing something
else
uh-uh yes every freaking week man
and no one here good one here no it
happened I first of all I have to ask
you about Jon taffer's rescue tour which
is what you're promoting because I
looked at it and at first I thought it
was like so it's like as you're getting
into the seminar business kind of it's
like a three and three and a half hour
thing with a lunch break and you're
training people and you're doing you're
giving people the secrets but these are
your tour dates I thought it was like
one event that you were promoting and
then I saw it's all summer from San Jose
to Long Island you said you like a
musician who just went to a divorce it's
27 weeks but I've been doing this a long
time so I've been doing this for 30
years guys so this is what I did for a
living before I went on television oh
you actually gave talks for seminars and
some beaches all over the world so
you're comfortable that's what I do you
know that's how I sort of got on TV as I
was doing one of those and somebody came
up to me and said you should be a TV man
and and really yes so the industry knows
me for this and this is what I do for a
living so I'll make them money when they
come that's so great to be able to when
the show is done on you can just do this
it's got to be so much less pressure you
just show up in the city it talks we're
finished
you know Bar rescue is is tough man but
what people don't know is and this is
what's interesting when I'm done two
things happens you know I get the
proverbial check mmm and I get a hug and
these days the hug almost means more
than the check you got so many checks
well yeah yeah now Bravo but you know I
get these emails every month of people
that say and I watch the show them in
Dubuque Iowa man and it made a
difference for me I made it so it's like
really inspiring and it like anything
had this BS reality platform because
we've installed cameras two days before
I get there you just got used to them
right so I mean if I walked into your
world and soap spoke to you that way
used to get the [ __ ] out of here right
but they allow me to do this because of
the fake platform
but yet on this fake platform it becomes
so freakin real yeah which is incredible
the reality is deeper because the
platform created it
yeah well normally they also are getting
something out of the two they know that
you despite all the getting yelled at is
that you're going to give them something
legit which is you're going to fix a
business that probably needs a lot of
work yeah honestly yes they think that
okay so he's going to come is going to
scream you yell at me I'll deal with it
and I'll get a remodel out of the deal
what they don't realize is it's [ __ ]
real to me yeah so I'm gonna you know
get in there and expose your freakin
demons because you know if you have a
failing business you are the failure man
you get it and you can see it in their
eyes when like John has figured
something out or saying something that
they didn't think would be on TV or they
didn't think that he was going to talk
about like they're like oh and that's
the moment where it gets like it stops
being this TV show where they get to
have new couches in their bar where it's
like oh my god this is this is really
this is real life yeah what are people
research on what do people resist the
most like what piece of advice or what
thing do you find that they it is the
one that for them most people is the
hardest accepting that it's them you see
they're always going to blame something
else it's the location it's the freaking
president is the euro
it's Greece you know yes it's that it's
snowed all [ __ ] winter it rained you
know they used to say it rained today no
business next day they'd say was the
first nice day no business right two
calls no business tonight snow business
everybody's out every day somebody has
an excuse so if you can blame someone
else then you've no reason to change man
but if you wake up in the morning and
say I'm failing because of me I'm the
ass then you're not going to like that
so I got to make you look in the mirror
and you know hold yourself responsible
that's between you and you because
there's all you explain that that's the
hardest part is getting people to admit
that they are self-destructive or
they're stupid or they're ruining their
own thing and horrible or ego oh yeah
because all there's always a little
truth of what they're saying like yeah
the weather does affect things a little
so instead of taking that that's ten
percent of your problem they make it
[ __ ] 90 percent of the problem you
know I mean like if they don't want to
be the 90 percent they're always a
little truth in it even if it's not a
bar even there's other businesses and
people are just self-destructive and
they blame everybody else do they suck
that's it's frustrating to get them to
look at themselves
you know just as a quick just popped in
my mind years ago we opened the place in
Seattle Washington with a huge deck and
everybody said there's a long time ago
everybody said to me drying it [ __ ]
knots of rains every day here who builds
a place where that outside deck we put
in these polls that came up from the
wooden deck and I had custom umbrellas
made that the slip into the pole so you
could pick up walk around with the
umbrella put it down it was really
successful we had these outdoor rain
happy hours and we turned it into
something right so my point is you can
make money in a rain if you're smart
right if you say oh I'm not going to
make money in a rain then you'll never
even have that slot in the first place
right so it's up to you you know what
kind of what kind of how quickly do you
know who the problem is right because I
mean there's always and you're saying
what I know who the problem is here
right away salmon it's not that a very
astute observation
you're off John you're way off on it up
he's good you know you can always find
that spot it's like a chain and you find
a weak link so if everything is screwed
up it's the leader right right if so
you're learning and the entire staff is
like they're not doing their job they're
not doing their job they're all bitter
they're all annoyed it's like well
that's that's the top that's not not is
right right cuz the whole staff hates
you it's got to be you where there's no
systems no procedures nothing you know
right everything is screwed up right or
you walk in you say well you know the
place is clean it is this it is that it
does have some redeeming elements so
maybe it's a manager not the owner how
maybe it's you know certain employees
right a certain like I've looked at bars
with the day shift is really together
the night shift is a freaking nightmare
so I mean there's things that can be
isolated or general to how how long did
it take you or is it just natural that
you got comfortable enough walking into
a place that you could act like you own
it because that's what you do you walk
into these bars and the second you walk
in you're in full control of it whether
they're offering you control or not like
I watch one I watched one yesterday I
was telling them about where I couldn't
believe you didn't get hit because you
go and you're like you're you you've
already pointed out all the flaws and
it's the it was a guy whose dad gave him
the bars the Indian guy who is like a
rich kid
and go back and you scrape the mold off
the after ice freezer and everybody's
freaking out and already discussed
already they're treating him like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] because he would allow
himself to have a bar with mold in the
ice freezer and you just because it
occurs to you goes you know what you
should wear this and you just take the
napkin and you wipe it down his white
shirt and I'm like where does he get the
balls to just think like that's what I'm
going to do right now well that all
happens in a moment yeah you know and
and you said an interesting thing and I
never we thought about this we said how
do you walk in and feel like an honor
right well I've owned these places
system 24 mm-hmm
so I certainly know how to walk through
it and feel like an owner and you know I
feel like it's mine and have the most
authority in a room so in bar and
nightclub environments I've had the most
authority in a room most of my adult
life honestly right so that's natural
that comes easy for mounting that think
twice about it
I got a lot of balls I'm pretty fearless
and there was an episode thinking season
two right cleared an entire bar of food
and I see is covered in sour cream I
don't know if you remember nobody eats
this food and my haha so what I did is I
guess I helped fired up I sent somebody
in to it was the Gulf themed bar forget
the name of it I sent somebody in and I
had them order everything on the menu so
the entire bar for about 12 feet are all
these plates of appetizers burgers
entrees and the kitchen was the most
disgusting I've ever seen and his food
is sitting out in a bar people waiting
to eat it for free so I go out and bar
my ammonite after that scene I could do
[ __ ] anything you know even think it
man it's still good you're filming it so
it's so great at TV but I didn't know I
was going to do that created it you know
I never know what I'm going to do until
I do it that's what's neat about the
show is I have complete freedom today I
follow you because I watch the show and
at what I don't remember how long I was
watching the show for but at some point
it just occurred to me like most of
these reality shows are pretty simple to
put together and throw together and you
could do them in a couple hours and
you're good but like this bar rescue
show has so many different establishing
shots and shot to this person making
something and now we're going here and
it's going to take two days to do this
like there is so much
time going into each episode just to get
everything that the story requires that
it's it's mind-blowing to me and we do
it in four days I mean we do actually
exhausting and we do remodel it in 36
hours and I'll tell you how we do in a
second but but you're right and the the
the extraction of the story yeah we
don't know what it is and we have a very
close common friend Keven Undergaro yes
who was a dear friend to both of us
elected me this morning decided that
you're a brother too so in any of it
he was shocked when he would come on a
show and do recon himself but what
happens is I know nothing when I show up
I literally get about a two and a half
minute briefing you know the it's owned
by Jim Jim's and a whole $400,000 his
wife is ready to leave of me as two kids
these houses on the line he's this he's
that he's that you know uh they hand me
a piece of paper which I designed the
format of which gives me market
demographics median age income you know
make up all that kind of stuff so I
glanced at the demographics I hear the
basic elements they put me in a chair I
get dressed I get right in the SUV Wow
I've been watch what's going on and
they're very many times the producers
will think story is John takes drunk
lounge turns it into you know MVP sports
bar that's what they hope is gonna
happen I show up on set say guys I'm not
putting a [ __ ] sports bar here you're
nuts so in the beginning everything they
thought I would do I didn't do now they
don't think anymore which it's really
complete freedom see they let you do
whatever you're anything tell you yeah
so one of the greatest SUVs stories of
all was some sitting in the SUV and get
ready to go and one of my producers
tells me in a Jawa we want the owner's
wife to do recon with you tonight right
owner's wife sits down to my SUV her
name was Edith and she had a gift bag
with her and I didn't know any what's a
gift bag for she goes that's my 14th
anniversary with my husband I said great
that's really nice tonight she goes yeah
and he's inside I said great would you
get him she says divorce papers Wow and
that's what she's got in the bag then we
sit down and we're watching a monitor in
the SUV and bar rescues real man and a
young girl walks up to her husband who's
apparently cheating I remember the
and said to her it says to him are you
married and he says there's no ring on
this finger I'm watching this with his
one
so she's besides herself you saw the
yeah yeah she runs into the bar throws
the drink in his face ripped his shirt
open and the two of them go at it four
days later they tore up the divorce
papers and about three months after that
nobody know it just knows this about
three months after that I got an email
from them they were having a baby
Wow a real Bar rescue list so we kind of
fixed them in some weird right they were
like clearly cliff and they're like [ __ ]
it let's just stick around you know you
get them to a place where I expose
everything it's it's ugly it was from
there there's only one way to go right
if it's real tell me the the mindset how
can somebody be so stupid to tell a
woman no ring on this finger even though
like they know that the place has been
wired with hidden cameras because they
know that the show is going to happen at
some point
how can a person be that stupid to
basically cheat on his wife in his bar
with the hidden cameras running
excellent question evolution yes not a
decision so he wasn't coming home at
night he was getting home drunk late at
night she was allowing it to happen
where I'll be over a period of time he
developed this comfort level of this is
what I knew that he actually did it with
my cameras in the building I mean that's
how comfortable yeah he was doing and
obviously the guy didn't do it on
purpose because the cameras are there
and lockup is married right [ __ ] right
yeah I'm thinking he gets so comfortable
sometimes you think you can't get caught
everyone always gets caught once they've
they like I can't get caught then you
get caught of course and the cameras are
there you said two days before you show
up yes so they're comfortable too built
in robo cameras that are built into the
place are there two days before I get
and you're recording everything yeah
also we always mess with them they think
I'm coming the next day I show up the
day early they think of at another bar
downtown to them they don't know which
of the two then they get a phone call
saying he's at the other bar and then I
laughing oh yeah I'll actually this is a
good one I'll actually install extra
lighting so let's say eight o'clock at
night the crew will walk in say he went
to another bar guys he's not coming in
down a couple of light fixtures suddenly
now okay now they're themselves [ __ ]
he's not coming let's go have some shots
I suddenly the reality kicks in wait
you're not coming to that bar ever or
just not not they think I'm not coming
I'm going to another one we're starting
to pull down rights so we they have to I
have to create reality yeah but I got
cameras and lights in the wall how do I
do that so it's a challenge so we're
constantly they don't know for sure that
I'm walking in that night never that's
why when they walk in to say oh [ __ ]
he's here right you'll see that reaction
that's so smart and you got them to sign
something is there something on the door
that tells patrons are coming in you're
being filmed ok cool everything's
covered so you can just say look we're
not coming yeah here we are
yeah or I can come to that I can come
three hours late they'll get so
frustrated they'll just start being
themselves they were all right right
he's not showing up if a may be here on
time you know so sometimes I got a waste
of the reality to take this course you
do get used to cameras it's really weird
you get you for you say things into a
Michael with cameras they're like FFF
few minutes it's just we're so used to
it now especially where's 30 years ago
maybe not but now everyone's got a
camera you don't even care anymore you
got a microphone tell you a lot of guys
you've had on your show that you know
sometimes say something they really
regret saying in the moment sure yeah no
you guys never have of course we with
you for three hours every day well I
wish that didn't happen I want to talk
about one of your topics four minutes
you guys we're talking about how you
can't get into bars correct in VIP list
will you not have my family was yeah I
would yes I was okay yes so what is the
dilemma so you you walk in you're not
recognized oh I'm worried right so I was
where our friend
well our colleague rich vos is having an
event tonight and I always whenever I
get invited to an event I always get
worried that I'm not going to be on the
list nobody's going to know who I am and
I'm just sitting there at the door like
a schlub you know I mean look like it's
yeah looking like a place he's basically
afraid and we're all 50 you get up there
it's a confirmation of what you already
know right
wow I'm not on the list I really am a
nonentity I know but you to hell I knows
who I am along even when they do they
don't care they don't laugh only I do
know you but no you can't convince right
weather or they're tweeting you see say
I'm waiting to get in and I want
that's hilarious so it's all designation
I mean you have to be marked on the list
a certain way so there's being on a
listen than is being on the VIP list
being uncomfortable list writing in
certain areas being in certain table
areas etc right so it isn't just being
on the list is how you're on the list
that matters yeah so next time you come
to Vegas I'll give you a lesson I'll
straighten you out on this yeah you get
me to the top of these lists I will get
you on the right list in the right place
and I'll teach you how this is done I
promise I'm never on lists either every
time there's nothing worse than when
they go through it and they're like uh
Norton I'm not uh when you see they go
back to the first page again you're like
I wasn't alone so worse feeling yeah I
did that I did it last time I had a WWE
show I pulled up to the parking lot just
because they changed their parking lot
thing and usually it's like the guy
there knows who I am so it's okay but
this time it was a different guy and
it's your [ __ ] and he was like what's
your name and I was like no and he pulls
out a list and I go no I could go just
Park in the regular panelist now and
walk across the street and every as I go
Sam like aren't you supposed to be yeah
yeah hi hi guys I'm gone in that way
every once in a while you meet an actor
who wears a hat with his own name and
logo on it you know what I mean you mean
I like that guy you just make certain
that you know so you know he's got he's
got the Jim Norton shirt Oh Jim Norton
hat you know what I'm saying that you
can't not know and then not only will
would say Jim Norton it'll say Sirius
radio blah blah blah I mean so he
establishes the credibility I used to
have a friend years ago who never had a
girl now he's probably 75 years old he
never had a girlfriend for more than
three weeks in his life this guy and
when he had a Ferrari and he had a limo
and he would send a limo driver to pick
up his dates and bring them back to him
so that the limo driver could set
everything up so the limo driver was
taught what to say and money that he had
is not demand he has in blah blah blah
so the pump was primed by the time he
got into the car so that's what some of
these guys do with the hat and the
shirts together sort of but how do you
walk around with your own
your chess and I'm and you so either
you're a putz for not being known yeah
we're a putz to having your name on your
shirt either way we wind up being a putz
in that situation yasou sends a limo
driver this this guy I want to discuss
what a smart move that is he's quite
younger girls hot younger women right he
was old typically yes and the limo
driver due to pump up so the girls get
in they throw oh that's so [ __ ] smart
so I'm taking it you know much about him
I'm taking you to see him and let me
tell you a little about him and blah
blah blah blah we they know that they
were being primed by it technically the
guy that was going to see or did he do
it away when they had no idea that no
idea suddenly he was running a little
late so they were picked up first
suggest a dryer now you gotta understand
when you start something with a
relationship with such total [ __ ]
that's why it lasts wrong for sure yeah
yeah yeah in a way was it it was
successful by the embarrassing radio
show you don't get season 2 you know
yeah that's it you you get up in and you
get in there once but sometimes you're
like you know what I didn't belong here
to begin with right I just be happy this
is supposed to be temporary it is only
temporary most guys never get this far
[ __ ] it we had sex a couple times I'll
just you know yeah best yeah so is he
still living is he still dating younger
women was he married no I'm sure he's
still trying oh good for ya I knows the
tricks he better be how long he lived in
Vegas Vegas close to four years now oh
you just went out of Camilla
okay why'd you go today as a couple
reasons actually I lived in Florida I
moved from LA to Florida matching
incorrect and I didn't expect bar rescue
to be such a hit tell you the truth I
thought I'd make a pilot and go home I
never expected this right I just
finished my hundred and forty seventh
episode been on the air now almost six
years we air 750 hours a year with these
Sunday marathons it's the most aired
show second most aired show on my
network
other than tomps Wow so the evergreen
nature and man yeah I never expected any
of this stuff and you know no you know
what year it is in 2009 I give you 2,000
matter that you said it's just but
people watch these marathons for 12
hours and they watch episodes again and
again I used to I used to so I used to
do a nighttime radio show so I wouldn't
get home until two o'clock in the
morning so I woke up at noon so I would
stay up at night so like on Sunday night
I would have that weird thing where you
know my wife had a regular job so she'd
go to bed at like 11 o'clock and I'd be
up until 3 o'clock in the morning and
that was my thing every Sunday I would
sit there because the bar rescues would
just never stop it would just be another
one and another one another one and it
got to the point where as much as that
show is on the air now if it's nighttime
and I turn on Spike and bar rescue isn't
on I get pissed I get emails yeah why
the bar rescue on and they skip the
sunday every once in a while for a
holiday some people are pissed where is
it right it's like they're used to
having a dick yeah it's a strange thing
you could have never predicted it so you
moved to Florida having no idea this
would go through the roof no because my
company was based in Florida and such
you know which is a big hospitality
State sure and we do consulting work you
know we develop hotels and restaurants
and bars we do serious work okay you
know we have fortune 500 clients big
corporations as well as small ones and
we have a multi multi-million dollar
consulting practice and then what make
you an Israeli company expense so camera
now the TV show became a success I'm
flying back and forth from Florida to LA
the trips killing me Jim it's a day back
computer some lose in three four days a
month going back and forth went so then
during first season of the TV show I
tried to fit the TV show into my other
wife yep first season was ten episodes
second season was ten episodes third
season was 40 episodes awful fourth
season was 50 episodes fifth season was
43 episodes and I just signed for 20
more much so
now the show didn't fit in my life I had
to fit my wife into the show so I had a
choice of moving to LA or moving to
Nevada and I chose Nevada taxes as you
said is one thing there's also a great
place do you gamble though the casinos
need to be so scary but I'm not a big
because that's how I got you know
another other businesses there too yeah
Thank You scares me it's a great place
to live I love Vegas probably afraid to
be though I'm so weak like and you know
my temptation I didn't gamble much but
I'm like I know I would if I was there
every day like I'd be bored one day I
gladly just try it and I'd win and I'd
be like [ __ ] and a week later I'm
blowin guys in the side of the road
everyone who wants
you'll see a husband and a wife and
again the elevator and a husband looks
at the wife and says give me the [ __ ]
money I told you not to get me well yeah
we shall say something to away he'll say
to her you lost $500 she goes I was you
lost $5,000 City says but I know how to
gamble you hear the most ridiculous
things between husband and wives women
blaming each other for losing the money
is a real tough phone so you're not on
the ship that you're no I'm I'm in
suburban okay when you linking whites
nearby yes when you started when the
show took off and you become this
television character you know does that
make the consulting business off TV more
difficult like it more difficult to be
taken seriously as a real consultant a
real businessman who's got legitimate
experience not just a guy who yells at
people on TV it's a great question sir
and and the credibility that I had of 30
years doing this before TV has helped
yes but when people meet me now who are
in the industry that don't know is now
if you google me or you see his TV right
you got to go back 500 pages to find a
real industry stuff on me so yes they
expect me to be a raving maniac right
expect me to be as professional as I am
and were you surprised at the at some of
the backlash that you get here in there
because and I feel like that happens to
anybody who gets like television
successful that like you've done stuff
while I was reading one thing where it
was like from a year ago two years ago
but like an interview that you had done
just about bars not about TV and people
in the industry are just picking apart
every little thing to try to make it
seem like this guy who's got a TV show
doesn't know what he's talking about
oh yeah I don't want to mention there
was one TV show I did where I was told
to make an old-fashioned so I go on the
show and they tell me what to set up so
I set it up on this you know I tell the
producers what I need so we have a
little counter on the side and it has
the ingredients for an old fashioned and
the show started with me on the couch
and then we got up to the second segment
to go to the bar to make the official as
I'm sitting on a couch the host says to
me I get a terrible problem John my
husband says I make a terrible Rob Roy
can you show me so I don't want to
correct our on our show so I said sure
figuring was a mistake
so we'd get up go to the table I start
making the old-fashioned is the old
version she goes doesn't a robber I have
sweet vermouth it does sure but there
was no sweet vermouth on the table I
thought I was making you're
old-fashioned right right so I'm not
going on live TV start arguing with so I
thought you'd I don't know what the how
to say so I let by the way if you go if
you're the guest and you start blaming
the producers to notice I make that's
not a possibility you can't do it so I
looked at her and sort of stumbled for a
second and said well you can make it
that way
well the bartending people are communion
with freaking nuts
Kappa doesn't know what's in an old
fashioned or what's in a Manhattan or a
Rob Roy instead of realizing that you
just stumbled at the awkwardness of a
live moment not one to correct the house
right and kill the like destroy the show
yeah that's it all going on they had a
bartender I'm a manager I'm a bar owner
mm-hmm you know Barrington there's you
know you can own a restaurant or not be
a chef like I don't know every recipe
how to attend the noddle I profess that
you don't know everything about the
boards and I know nothing about the
board Sarah believe me they're happy to
point it out exactly you know you know
what I'm saying sure I'm a management
job but did that kind of shocked you
when like because you hadn't been
necessarily in the public eye to that
extent when you now have to deal with
just everybody having an opinion about
you positive or negative but I think it
starts to I mean I know for me and I
think probably for Jim to when you start
to realize like oh people are allowed to
just have negative opinions about you
and they can snowball it and and it
becomes a thing when that first starts
to happen is that kind of like whoa
first time it the first time or two it
happened it was yes yeah Wow you know it
was offensive yeah you know you're
really you're really thinking oh geez
why would people do that you know don't
they understand and you say to yourself
I'm a good guy load but you know 24
hours that stuff blows over now it's
gone it's gone and the fact is none of
it has ever rooted because you know you
got to look at the body of your work
right and if 95% of it is and then these
things tend to disappear now they don't
bother me at all sent a literature you
know it's fun I laugh out and there's
some people say I have a turtleneck that
my neck looks oh I can look like in the
[ __ ] turn your are the people that
talk about my bug eyes are going to pop
out just people so if I laugh at it now
I think it's sort of funny because of
your perfectly handsome guy your
unique-looking guy and that's all that
matters you don't have to be model
handsome I'm just telling them speak I
have the mirror every morning no I hang
myself you're right Tim it did bother me
right but you know you do get thicker
skin and it does sort I want to ask you
about the Troubadour to that that's
that's on Santa Monica Boulevard riders
and I catch that a lot they always have
these amazing performers there and you
were there for how many years so for
about two years two and a half years and
what did you do that you just you just
the marketing manager story as a doorman
left his manager and did you see some
cool people come to they're incredibly
cool people you know in 78 79 80 with
the kind of years that I was dairyman
those with a black flag Dead Kennedys
Adam and steer kind of dazed at the same
time that that whole punk scene was
going on you know a new wave with the
clean-cut suits you know and so it was
an interesting time in rock and roll
yeah heavy metal is starting its roots
you know and not only was it a
troubadour there are places like Madame
Wong's back then and Hong Kong and
whiskey and Starwood it was a great time
back then how much harder is to work in
a music place when you're as far as a
bar it's been a regular just a
traditional are you got a lot of music
you know the troubadour was three bands
a night seven nights a week sometimes
more I mean that can [ __ ] get the ax
Jim you know I mean your heads pounding
sometimes sometimes you just got to walk
outside you know I guess yep you know
five minutes of non thump how does the
band's to deal with advance difficult to
deal with I've heard makes really
sometimes you love work on the band and
you know I can tell stories of when I
ran a troubadour you know some some
household names and I never seen in some
household names you know we come down
from San Francisco big rock stores today
with no money and I'd let him sleep in a
troubadour the night before because they
had no money really and they were
gigging the next day and they were out
of those stores and they would hang out
and play there was there was sometimes
sleeping there the night before I'd have
to feed him excedrin play the next day
now some of them are very famous so what
are you friendly with them or you didn't
like them uh no I didn't like him I
wouldn't let him stay in hindsight you
know I'm guessing the talent I just ezel
Cameron TISCO my guess is me telling you
know I came home lessons we don't
so when I moved to LA to work at the
Troubadour I was a musician myself right
I was I was a musician myself so I
related to them you know and I
understood how hard it was so my entire
life I've respected that so I got along
really well with them writers - how do
you realize like that yet because I'm
assuming at some point in life you
thought drumming is my passion drumming
is what I'm going to do how do you later
in life realize that this thing that I
thought was my dream my passion my is
not what I'm going to do with my life
I'm going to do this other thing that
I'm and potentially even more passionate
about here's interesting when I play the
drums I took lessons for years jazz
lessons and I never ever said to myself
and I was a kid that I wanted to be a
rap star that was never I want to play
two joints of playing drums right I know
I really loved reading the music and and
you know and playing it and played it
all the time it was really a passion to
me you know you can play baseball as a
kid would never expect to be a
professional baseball player right I
just not getting paid in college - so
what happened was through music I got
exposed to the nightclubs once exposed
to the nightclubs I really loved the
operations part and stuff so if anyone
migrated to the others yeah happen Sam
but it wasn't that I consciously left
one for the other it's that I really
liked what I was doing today so he did
it again tomorrow did it again the next
day and there you go plus drumming's of
[ __ ] man drummers are always the
first ones to go because it's just so
hard on your body as you see do you see
uh
beware of mr. Baker yeah of course of
course you know I love him but he is one
feisty dude he's psychotic we could say
he was one [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean
[ __ ] on John Bonham like he wasn't
that great he feels he's the best in the
world but he got a taste when they did
their Royal Albert Hall and Madison
Square Garden gig and he was 68 years
old up there drumming a few years ago
came some respect yeah but you're right
he's not the kind of guy you want to
travel in a small plane he's very
difficult yeah could you imagine
spending a month with him in a tour bus
I've worked with people who are
difficult before but even then never on
that level of psychotic is he sound like
you would hit people success my scream
didn't stay together yeah we need that
good and nobody wants to work with you
is a problem yeah and then you look at a
guy like Clapton to work with it was a
decent guy I love the fact that he just
showed up and known had the hard time we
don't want you in the band anymore such
a psychopath nobody wanted to tell him
you're out of the band so he just played
the rehearsal studio I don't know what
happened I guess it must be I want to
ask you about a about an invention of
yours that I've talked about on the
radio a lot because I talked about
especially when I was doing my nitro you
staff our rescue hold on because I
watched it so much but you are the
inventor of the bus funnel is that right
I am I'm a fan of the but funnel you've
talked about it on many an episode it is
it is a contraption Jim in a bar where
you just kind of put two they could be
half walls or cylinders or whatever it
is but it's meant so that two people
have to cross through this smaller area
and they go either but to butter front
to front but it is it is it is designed
it is architectural II designed to
increase social interactivity so you're
heading to the dance floor you got to go
through the Buffalo this narrow entry
way now if you want to avoid that you
can go around and avoid it but let's say
there's a hot girl approaching the floor
so you time yourself to the bunt funnel
so the two of you go through the but
funnel at the same time now you might go
through face to face that's a score that
I score yeah I mean your faces are
inches you got to look in each other's
eyes you got to say hello
it forces what you can try to try for
some pelvis a sure so they come on
you're sick [ __ ] come on you could do
yeah so and really excited cuz you're
getting close and she's still facing you
right so you're convinced you going
through face to face last minute she
spins and you're facing her ass as you
go through so it's basically the fetish
is called frottage where people rub
against you yeah I had that in high
school or Grey's acid that's basically
an excuse to graze like in high school
it's phenomenal I would love to you but
it creates that contact yeah does it
people interact more is it just make for
an awkward like scuse me scuse me or
they smile they don't you know they
laugh remember the music is playing it's
a festive environment it's not a
supermarket where would first rate you
right right now just handbags nobody is
this you know I have no rapping those
mom
five zero ability everybody's watching
out for the Jim Norton creep who just
hangs out next to the butt funnel all
night we have a hot girl to go into
exactly I kick ass I Alice in the
parking lot I want a buckle fix it one
time he jumps he thinks his timing is
right here it's full of course you're
getting walked on and somebody else goes
through the butt funnel by themselves
that's the worst thing for me is those
bars and nightclubs and liquid there's a
beauty my self-esteem nosedives no
ability to communicate knows there's a
visit art to being in those places and
security you know I don't drink much and
the reason why I don't is because when I
was coming up in his business for years
and I watch people make complete asses
of themselves ya heard every pick-up
line every turn down line you know so so
guys that are worst you know night after
night after night so you know it taught
me to keep my [ __ ] together I didn't
want to be one of those guys yeah yeah I
mean and and yeah because then you can
actually use your brain to try to
communicate on a level plus if you're
drunk you may stumble when you're trying
to get into the butt funnel and that's
the last thing you want to do when you
get into it you know releases a guy
before her coming in y'all [ __ ] off you
take it kind of [ __ ] what he hits you
like why'd you jump in the bus [ __ ] why
are you still facing me Achilles do it I
don't know what you what a great quick
treatment our story yeah so late
seventies Your Honor the Troubadour
decides he's going to give the nightclub
to Native Americans this night was a
fundraiser and this was before Indian
Gaming when the Native American
community was really struggling
economically so in a troubadour that
night were Indian comics Indian drummers
in the availa Indian artists a whole it
was a great place even the guy who
played chief in One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's lost half their famous
Hollywood Indians are there you know
blah blah blah and it's a real you know
serious fundraiser for them this was the
day that the Washington Redskins lost a
football game in the last couple minutes
against the Cowboys I believe it was in
a playoffs neither would have put him in
the next round or the Super Bowl I feel
it was I had a $20 bet with a friend of
mine who was an entertainment lawyer I
was standing at the end of the
Troubadour bar drinking ginger ale guy
walks through the front door the game
had just ended and screams at the top of
his arms those [ __ ] Redskins in a
room of 400 Native Americans
so he walked through the front door the
Troubadour expecting the normal
rock-and-roll crowd so I'm a scream from
20 feet away those [ __ ] Redskins I
looked up I didn't even notice it at the
time today the truth he screamed at his
second time Hawking Redskins
and they broke his collarbone was one
really it was one of the worst
misunderstandings I ever remember it
they thought just mad that they were in
the bar he was being an [ __ ] he was
actually one of you know most non
[ __ ] but they cannot rata tissue guys
in the world what because he said it
twice right reamed and he said it in
anger yes [ __ ] me [ __ ]
in hindsight that's hilarious yeah that
sounds so silly when it was over the
game the gay all right all right sorry
sorry sleeve there was a closet by the
front bar and the bathrooms are all the
way in the back so during a show but if
you're a bartender you got to take a
leak there's a line back there so you
can't leave the bar sure and not come
back for a half hour just so they would
have these big glass Tropicana orange
juice bottles and they keep them in the
closet by the bar so you'd pee in a
bottle leave it the shelf that but one
day I walked into the closet it had a
spring on the door slam and freaking
thing fell off the shelf at before and
piss all over the floor so they asked
you what you're doing these uh you see
bugs and like like rodent conditions you
do right very often we've seen rats
we've had actually rats walk into our
feet and you actually feel it hit your
shoe that's I saw one where there's a
raccoon in the ceiling yes there's a
raccoon in the bar raccoons are almost
like they can come in from the roof they
can jump off a tree like a background
ceiling with [ __ ] in the holes in
the drop ceiling and audacity on the
freakin bar that's been a good [ __ ] on
the heart okay yeah I did I didn't take
it that many steps I saw the cute to
have a little guys scampering around not
realizing he'd be [ __ ] my wife did
recon for me no remember headhunters
headhunters episode in Austin Texas my
wife does recon this was a class-five
infestation oh yeah yeah
so as my wife is sitting next to me
there bugs walking across her toes in
her open showed to she freaked told me
to go [ __ ] myself
what add to the bar quite as much as the
worst investigation shut it down we had
we showed it yeah those really discussed
make it that we fix it how do you think
you just debug the whole thing and then
talk about weather coming up production
down for a day and deal with these
matters I've had a four collapse we had
to shut down production and deal with
Murphy's Law that episode I've had you
know how to shut down for fumigating
right I can't do it if it's unsafe Maria
they would neither that's really
irresponsible to fix it put your name on
it and make it still it you know a
health trap well it's also that the
liquor there's so much sugar and stuff
on the Bob that's going to attract a lot
of insects if you know those are the
bottles we see one of my great stories
this was a dual nightclub to something
called a hydrometer a hydrometer tests
the alcohol level in a liquor bottle so
there's a particular call brand gin I
won't mention the name that's 86 proof
so I take that bottle I put it down I
put the hydrometer in it it's only 80
proof so neither somebody's pouring
water in that bottle or they're taking
cheap gin bar gin which is 80 proof and
our premiums in bondages so I've seen
that you know all sorts of room do you
test a lot of the bottles it sure is
that what they have the hydrometer will
inspectors never go ahead and test them
to make sure that you serve it they will
you bet they will so you can't water it
down without fear of repercussion that
you could get in trouble like legally
for that yes as a matter of fact it was
an incident not too long ago year year
and a half ago with a restaurant chain I
won't say which one in New Jersey the
franchisee was busted putting bad liquor
in and even putting tea and stuff in the
liquor bottles and I'm yeah and it was a
national chain franchisee who did it
what's the what's the purpose of doing
that if you know someone's going to you
stupid they find I mean they find bugs
in the ice bins so you know where they
scoop up the ice like there's bugs at
the bottom of it they find bugs like you
said in the liquor bottles so like you
just hold it up to the light you can see
the dead bugs at the bottom of the
bottle that they're pouring from the one
that I was talking about where he wiped
the the bowl of the guy's shirt there is
dead mice right behind the wall okay
what wasn't living or bacterial that I
found behind a bar trivia question for
you soon it wasn't alive there wasn't
dirt or felt but it was incredibly
disgust
I don't remember used condom oh I do
remember that one yeah you yeah them
sitting under the sink behind the bar in
the bar like not like and I'm trying to
drive honey butter yeah aha in the thing
like some of you and just thrown I hate
that is disgusting and the idea that you
had to use one yeah I hate the fact that
he had more moral courage would you use
it twice they actually might have shared
it maybe yeah with your do a favorite
episode I think my favorite episode was
the Big Mike's episode they did recently
with the Baton Rouge floods oh yeah you
know that one also the you know the one
I'm here in New York from Rockaway Beach
bungalow bar meant a lot to me which was
after superstorm sandy
so you liked the one yeah I remember
that one you like the ones that are like
there's a good story behind it and they
really deserve some help I like the ones
where you end up leaving and don't even
help well that's great tea I like that
you know and those are great episodes
but those are really miserable when you
I mean when I walk away it's because the
guy was such an [ __ ]
imagine how unpleasant those four days
were for me you know what happened when
your walk in you're not going to fix the
place what will it be like this guy is
just not going to listen or he's an
[ __ ] who doesn't know it's hammered
or I won't do it you know because I
think in one case and you probably
talking about the Oh face yeah yeah in
one case you know the owner was was
slapped an employee was physical with
his employee so once I learned that I
said you know I'm not going to
perpetuate this so I didn't he raised a
stink I Witter Lee walked out said you
know f you a much I'm not going to do
your bar left them hanging you know they
caused a big stink and stuck to my guns
and about a year and a half later he was
arrested for sexual harassment of an
employee Wow right not to deal with them
here I do do you ever get worried I mean
you're not a small guy but do you ever
get worried that you're going to do a
physio somebody at least looking out for
you like a guy that travels with you I
have a security guy you do okay but only
in the past year before that I never did
you didn't what you were never afraid is
healing a physical that was a big
concern of our offering Keven Undergaro
yeah I never had secured he never
claimed that on a pretty big guy and you
know I'm about verbal confidence and
typically you don't mess with a guy who
has a is displaying a real lot of
confidence
plus your there they know why you're
there I like your your your [ __ ]
ambushing them they know you're there
but you could still have a situation
where like like like a battered wife
scenario where you go to arrest a
husband and the wife is going to defend
the husband even though he's hitting or
like you go and you're you start
[ __ ] on the owner this bar is
treating a staff poorly you you know you
make whatever your comments you want to
make he hits you if you're going to
swing back all of a sudden his staff
that you're there to help they're going
to jump on you it's like yeah it's crazy
not security
I dunno so they're too like are there
two possible so you say go to Louisiana
and you go to New Orleans are there two
possible bars you're going to do and two
are wired for camera are you only doing
one we if I'm going that typically will
do three in the city gym because the
economics work okay because we travel
with a crew of about 57 five big trucks
big production yeah so once we travel to
a city it takes three to make the
economics work sometimes four okay I
never do less than three in our city so
how long we say in the city for
sometimes the BART can drop out a week
before production for example we have to
do background checks all that kind of
stuff so sometimes we find out that in
paying taxes they committed fraud they
got arrested there's a criminal
background okay you know so sometimes
they close I've written checks to keep
the lights on while we're there I mean
that's how much trouble we're in Wow
what I like we're closing today if you
don't help but yes the lights shut down
after we arrived you know we're going to
shooting the lights are turned off have
you uh have you interacted always chef
Gordon Ramsay I'm kind of hearing he had
not mad at never we've you know sent
niceties back and forth to each other
yeah you know on social media and
through some common friends we share
some crew members together how you do
yeah I think we I know a lot respect for
Gordon I'm guessing he does me yeah
we're very different you know he's a
chef owner businessman we come at it
very differently yeah it sells out we're
alike but we're very different than we